[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité la jeunesse au
volant des 17 ans l'an prochain il sera
possible de conduire avant la majorité
un abaissement de l'âge du permis qui
fait réagir concerner ses professionnels
comme nous le montrera Vosges télévision
jardinier agriculteur il cherche la
parade à la sécheresse les rédactions de
Wéo TV de 8 Mont-Blanc nous dévoilerons
les astuces déployées par les amateurs
comme les professionnels pour faire face
au mando cet été sur le territoire
surveillez le courant grâce à un
hélicoptère la rédaction de Canal 32
nous expliquera elle la technique
aérienne employée par enedis pour
surveiller ses équipements dans l'Aube
et puis en fin de journal la rédaction
de lmtvart nous conduira dans les
coulisses d'une vente aux enchères
historique celle de bolide qui ont
marqué les 24 Heures du Mans voilà vous
serez des millions sur la route c'était
direction les vacances bien mérité pour
certains bien sûr et parmi les autom
êtes coincer probablement dans les
embouteillages deux jeunes conducteurs
prendront le volant pour la première
fois aujourd'hui à 18 ans l'année
prochaine il sera possible de conduire
des 17 ans selon une annonce récente
gouvernementale une mesure qui ne laisse
personne insensible notamment dans les
auto-écoles ou chez les concessionnaires
comme ont pu le constater à Lexi
Rodriguez et Anne Didier pour voter
à 17 ans Sarah est inscrite dans une
auto-école encore hésitante au volant la
jeune conductrice c'est pourtant quelle
route elle veut suivre
que ça dépend de chacun d'individu parce
que certains sont en apprentissage il
travaille donc la voiture peut être
nécessaire pour faire des trajets mais
après certains n'ont peut-être pas non
c'est peut-être pas autonome
actuellement l'âge moyen d'obtention du
permis de conduire est estimé à 23 ans
il y a quelques jours la première
ministre Elisabeth borne évoquait la
possibilité de passer l'examen dès l'âge
de 17 ans une mesure qui pourrait être
mise en place en 2024 les élèves en
conduite accompagnés peut passer son
permis à 17 ans alors bien évidemment
elle peut pas conduire toute seule
jusqu'à ses 18 ans donc c'est un système
qui a fait ses preuves ça fait ça existe
depuis plus de 20 ans aujourd'hui les
accidents de la route sont la première
cause de mortalité chez les 18-24 ans
cette nouvelle mesure suicide donc des
questionnements à 17 ans le jeune qui
prend une voiture si un accident quel
risque pénal il aura est-ce que les
assurances vont suivre aussi
où il y aura peut-être une surprise
voyez tout ça c'est un coup derrière
autre possibilité pour les jeunes qui
souhaitent conduire avant leur majorité
les 100 p comme il les appelle ou
voiture sans permis ces voitures
limitées à 45 km/h sont de plus en plus
présentes sur les routes dans cette
concession en enlevant une centaine par
an entre 10000 et 16000 euros selon le
modèle en France le nombre s'élevé appli
de 9500 en 2019 et à quasiment doublé en
2021 grosses évolution c'est l'arrivée
d'une nouvelle clientèle la clientèle
jeune les 14-18 ans la principale raison
c'est la spéc sécurité surtout pour les
parents aujourd'hui de savoir leur
enfance en les cultes carénées protéger
à l'abri c'est quand même plus
sécurisant que sur un cyclomoteur si
cette mesure est définitivement adoptée
par le gouvernement la France
deviendrait le sixième pays européen à
autorisé les mineurs de 17 ans à
conduire sans être accompagné le record
mondial et lui détenu par certains états
des États-Unis où les jeunes peuvent
prendre le volant seul des 14 ans
voilà et peu importe votre âge restez
prudent au volant et pensez à faire des
pauses en direction des vacances les
vacances justement continuons d'en
parler avec cette problématique bien
connue à quelques jours du début de la
haute saison les professionnels n'ont
toujours pas complété leurs équipes et
saisonniers manquent à la pelle exemple
sur le Bassin d'Arcachon avec ce sujet
de Linda boudjroudy pour TV7 la chaîne
du groupe sud-ouest bonjour à tous Le
restaurant chez Geneviève situé sur le
port de Bordeaux
à quelques jours du démarrage de la
saison 5 postes restent toujours à
pourvoir dans son restaurant aujourd'hui
je dirais qu'il me manque surtout un
cuisinier
éventuellement un plongeur et une
serveuse restaurant et une serveuse
barre avec une rémunération de 2200
euros pour 42 heures par semaine et
logement compris il ne parvient pas à
trouver du personnel
le logement c'est devenu très très
compliqué pour pour se loger sur le
Bassin d'Arcachon parce que les loyers
sont excessivement cher les l'immobilier
et accessiblement cher alors du coup
mais aujourd'hui alexis a voulu donner
sa chance à Juliette habitant sur le
bassin pour un premier jour d'essai de
l'autre côté du bassin Arcachon même
galère pour les restaurateurs
en ce moment ouais parce qu'il nous
manque du personnel dans cette zone très
touristique les annonces sont nombreuses
sur les vitrines Marvin lui a fait le
choix de recruter des mineurs pour
travailler dans son restaurant pour la
saison
qui voulaient juste venir travailler et
tous les jours j'essaye de les de les
former au mieux mais je pense que la
saison
va bien se dérouler il y aura pas de
problème faut juste être très patient
donner des bonnes conditions de travail
payer les gens correctement c'est le cas
de Paul plongeur pour la saison je sais
que c'est heure par jour et je commence
pas très tôt je commence à 10h et je
suis à 17h sur les 150 000 postes
saisonniers ouverts l'année dernière
dans la restauration la moitié serait
encore approuvée
voilà et cet été en plus du manque de
saisonnier la pluie se fait elle aussi
très discrète par tout en France déjà
plusieurs dizaines de départements sont
placés en vigilance ou soumis à des
restrictions une situation qui n'est pas
sans impact bien sûr interdiction
d'arroser les pelouses de remplir les
piscines les particuliers sont obligés
de s'adapter exemple dans un jardin
familial de la Somme où l'on redouble
d'astuces pour économiser la ressource
en eau et limiter l'arrosage face au
changement climatique les pratiques
évoluent comme la constaté Jérôme
moubron pour eux TV la chaîne de la Voix
du Nord et du Courrier Picard
c'est une histoire qui semble se répéter
pour Jean-Louis le jardinier envisageait
de se mêler ici quelques légumes mais
face au manque d'eau il doit revoir ses
plans tout ce qu'on va semer petite
graine
n'avait carotte et tout comme ça et ben
il faut garder de la terre humide humide
et là ici chez ben voilà c'est
ça part en poudre
ça va être le problème comme la dernière
l'été commence à peine que déjà la somme
accuse un déficit de précipitation
obligeant la préfecture à limiter
l'usage de l'eau et là l'eau elle va
bien à la plante la même quantité d'eau
si je la mettais au pied ça irait de
partout bouteille de plastique pour
optimiser la rosace ou paillage pour
conserver l'humidité pas le choix pour
sauver leur récolte les jardiniers
redouble d'astuces là on est parti là on
nous dit le réchauffement climatique oui
oui et ben j'ai mis mes carottes avant
j'ai eu mes petits pois avant là ils
sont récoltés ça y est c'est fini les
tomates je les ai faites avant et là
elles sont magnifiques changements
climatique oblige les pratiques évoluent
il y a quatre ans Didier a opté pour la
permaculture dans ses buts épluchures de
légumes et autres végétaux ont des
compositions viennent protéger et
alimenter ces plans de pommes de terre
ce n'est peut-être pas esthétique mais
depuis le jardinier se passe d'arrosage
à l'intérieur de la butte la terre elle
est elle est humide elle est noire
j'ai pas besoin d'arroser c'est humide
tout seul puisqu'elle
est elle est comment protéger par par
tout ce qu'il y a de paillage sur une
butte de patates comme ça j'ai ouais
j'ai fait samedi j'ai fait 15 kg mais
des belles pommes de terre
tous les moyens sont bons pour
économiser l'eau ressources
indispensables à la vie des potagers
d'autant que l'épisode de sèche reste
pourrait s'installer dans le temps
depuis le mois de mai la région
Hauts-de-France ne compte que deux jours
de précipitations
une sécheresse qui impacte vous le savez
déjà une bonne partie du territoire en
savoir les agriculteurs font face eux
aussi aux aléas climatiques à l'heure
des premières récoltes estivales le
bilan n'est pas si mauvais mais reste
très fragile les précisions d'Emmanuel
Joe pour la chaîne 8 Mont-Blanc regarder
installez depuis quelques années sous le
col de gorgé en Savoie le GAEC des
paysans voyageurs vit au fil des saisons
comme chaque début d'été l'arrivée des
moins chauds est synonyme de récolte des
fruits rouges qui ont cette année
bénéficié de conditions assez optimales
alors au niveau des petits fruits c'est
pas mal parce qu'on a eu pas mal d'eau
et les petits fruits ils sont bien
développés et du coup on a une belle
année parce qu'il y a quand même eu de
la pollinisation il y a pas eu de gel
tardif donc les fleurs elles vont
jusqu'au bout là on peut se regarder les
différentes grappes on a quand même des
Belges grappes par exemple
et ce qui est chouette avec un printemps
plus vieux c'est que on a des belles
pousses et des belles pousses de cette
année ça va être les fruits de l'année
prochaine car c'est justement la gestion
de cette ressource en eau qui va
déterminer la qualité de cette saison
2023 en effet si les préfectures de nos
départements ont déjà pris plusieurs
mesures et arrêtées afin de prévenir les
épisodes de sécheresse attendus pour les
prochains mois les agriculteurs eux se
préparent en payant les sols et on se
gardant bien de dresser des des
premières tendances sur ce début de
saison vous voyez la météo elle est
toujours un peu incertaine on nous
annonce toujours des orages
potentiellement de la grêle les gros
coups de vent donc ce qui est ramassé
c'est ramassé ce qui est pas ramassé
il y a toujours un risque que ça reste
par terre ou que ça se trouve abîmé quoi
j'ajouterai un bémol sur le verger ou
tout ce qui est fruit à noyau où là
justement le printemps assez frais et
très humide a fait que il y a beaucoup
de fleurs qui ont coulé et pour faire
face à cette incertitude météorologique
récurrente nombreux sont les producteurs
de fruits et légumes de nos territoires
qui à l'image des paysans voyageurs ont
choisi d'investir dans des systèmes de
stockage d'eau pluviales une façon de
minimiser l'impact du dérèglement
climatique sur des cultures plus que
jamais essentielles à notre quotidien
voilà et le monde agricole s'invite
aussi à Paris dans ce journal la chaîne
francilienne 20 minutes TV c'est glissé
dans une séance d'initiation à
l'agriculture urbaine à Bobigny sur
place les bénévoles apprennent quelques
règles basiques du potager un sujet de
Mélanie fort regardez ce reportage
pour faire la fête il faudra attendre
demain comme tous les vendredis la
prairie du canal ouvre ses portes pour
accueillir ses bénévoles au programme du
repiquage de basilic avec tadet
on se retrouve avec pas mal de petites
plantules qu'on va regrouper dans un
seul godet on va en mettre 5 je vais
choisir mes petits plans et je vais
planter repiquer le
petit bouquet de basilic à l'intérieur
rapidement les bénévoles prennent leur
marque avec le sourire un peu dur un peu
dur bah ils sont super sympas
franchement ils sont accueillants et
même quand on arrive
un petit café on est bien
ensemble cette expérience de bénévolat
donne le coup d'envoi de leur week-end
une activité mûrement réfléchie
c'est plutôt parce que les plantes ça
m'intéresse et du coup j'avais envie
d'apprendre un peu plus les jardinages
l'agriculture bio je trouve ça important
sous la serre le soleil fait grimper la
température mais pas de quoi décourager
Naomi qui vient tous les vendredis j'ai
appris à semer à repiquer les plantes
parce que je viens de la campagne mais
au final j'ai jamais vraiment aidé mes
parents pour le jardin j'ai aussi appris
moi par exemple à monter une serre on a
fait du bricolage on a fait des tables
des bancs des onguières on un après-midi
les bénévoles état des repiques en
moyenne une centaine de basilic dans
quelques jours ils seront disponibles à
la vente
de l'agriculture urbaine au champ de
canne à sucre martiniquais dans ce JT la
rédaction devient à TVA a rencontré un
cultivateur alors que la récolte de la
canne à sucre touche à sa fin
actuellement à 43 ans Willy Louzi Daniel
est propriétaire aujourd'hui d'une
vingtaine d'hectares les pieds sur terre
il est conscient des difficultés du
métier mais n'envisage pas pour
l'instant une reconversion un sujet de
Loïc Régis regardez
au début des années 2000 où il y
découvre les métiers de la canne aux
côtés de son père lui-même travailleur
de la terre une expérience enrichissante
pour lui la graine est semée il en fera
aussi son activité principale ça
mène
aussi
de connaître les mots difficiles
d'apprendre à que c'est pas un métier
facile déjà amoureux de la terre il se
développe au fil des années il exploite
un hectare au départ une vingtaine
aujourd'hui pour atteindre ses objectifs
Willy a réalisé de nombreux
investissements satisfaction personnelle
de pouvoir grandir de pouvoir
s'améliorer de d'investir
de pouvoir aussi créer des emplois alors
que la campagne 2023 toucha sa fin le
quadra génère tire un bilan plutôt
positif de ces récoltes si tout n'est
pas parfait les motifs de satisfaction
sont nombreux notamment en termes de
quantité la récolte
[Musique]
le rendement n'était pas trop mauvais je
pense qu'on tourne autour des 60 tonnes
70 tonnes 70 honnête temps pilotin
assumé Willy Louisy Daniel travaille
majoritairement avec la distillerie
lamonie comme lui il existe un peu moins
de 200 producteurs de canne à sucre en
Martinique
allez tout à fait autre chose dans cette
édition parlons à présent de réinsertion
en milieu carcéral une prison de Moselle
organisée il y a quelques jours une
rencontre entre employeur et détenus
objectif préparé pour les candidats leur
avenir professionnel et se donner ainsi
une seconde chance un contrat de travail
pour la liberté un sujet de lucifilippo
pour Moselle TV
de Sarreguemines mais avant cela il doit
préparer sa sortie prévue prochainement
à partir
avec bracelet peut-être
rencontrer des agences d'intérim c'est
pour lui le meilleur moyen d'obtenir un
travail une fois sorti de prison pour
moi c'est important parce que ça
consiste déjà la réaction au moins en
sortant d'ici on peut déjà avoir un
contrat ou un truc en intérim à CDI à
CDD Justine
je dans une agence d'intérim l'aidera
dans son insertion professionnelle une
fois dehors
d'encourager et de les motiver à les
accompagner à la sortie pour les aider à
se remettre un peu dans le droit chemin
ce sont des changes professionnels
intervient dans le programme de la
semaine de réinsertion organisé par la
prison et ce n'est pas la première fois
que les jobs dating s'invitent ici
premier job dating qu'on a réussi sur 17
personnes on avait 10 personnes qui
avaient des propositions n'ont pas
réelles là on peut pas l'estimer parce
que c'est en cours mais on voit aussi
qu'il y a déjà beaucoup de retours
positifs sur les 88 détenus de
Sarreguemines 30 ont pu bénéficier de
ces échanges trouver un emploi
faciliterez leur sortie et permettrait
une meilleure réinsertion dans la
société si trouver un travail suffisait
à lutter contre la récidive ce serait
très bien mais malheureusement c'est pas
c'est pas la c'est pas la situation
idéale il y a d'autres freins à
l'insertion que l'insertion
professionnelle c'est un des aspects
mais si on réjou déjà celui-là on résout
celui de je dirais de la place dans la
société des ressources financières donc
du coup ça facilite l'accès au logement
une fois libre les anciens détenus
seront toujours suivis pour éviter les
risques de récidive
de la hauteur sur la ligne direction
l'aube ou enedis effectue en ce moment
un contrôle aérien des lignes à haute
tension du département un hélicoptère
permet ainsi d'inspecter plus de 200 km
d'équipement par jour un travail
effectué chaque année pour le bon
entretien du réseau les détails avec ce
reportage de Christian Vieira pour Canal
c'était l'hélicoptère devrait voler à
très basse altitude entre trois semaines
et deux mois objectif répertorié de
façon préventive tous les défauts sur
près de 9000 km de lignes de moyenne de
tension en Champagne-Ardenne et défauts
avec un appareil photo mon collègue qui
à l'avant lui va m'envoyer en fait un
point GPS dans un logiciel qui est
propre à nous des équipes à pied vont
peut-être parcourir trois quatre
kilomètres le drone va effectuer une
dizaine une quinzaine grand maximum de
kilomètres par jour mais forcément
l'hélico pour du traitement de volume de
masse comme ça en faisant 200 220 km en
gros à la journée et vraiment la toux
idéal pour ça il faut pas s'inquiéter
ces jours-ci si un hélicoptère qui vole
dans l'Aube très bas normalement ce sera
nous dans l'Aube ce prestataire
sollicité par enedis survolera près de
580 km de lignes 20.000 volts se
contrôle est effectué tous les ans en
complément des interventions à pied
grâce au trône on ne peut pas voir les
mêmes défauts quand on est à pied que
quand on est en hélicoptère ça peut être
un câble détourné on ne peut pas le voir
à vue d'oeil ça peut être une attache de
ligne qui est endommagée à l'objectif de
fond c'est évidemment de définir un
programme d'entretien à l'avant de
l'engin leader permet d'effectuer
d'autres types de mesure si nécessaire
au sol un coéquipier suit le trajet afin
de ravitailler l'hélicoptère si besoin
l'appareil qui est devant l'hélicoptère
c'est un leader c'est un système qui
permet essentiellement de détecter la
végétation autour des lignes la hauteur
entre les lignes et le sol en 2022 9,4
millions d'euros ont été consacrés au
programme d'entretien des lignes en
Champagne-Ardenne
pas de diamant noir mais un maillot
jaune pour le Tour de France la grande
boucle qui a débuté le 1er juillet
dernier fait étape cette année dans la
ville de Limoges une occasion unique
pour l'économie locale de mettre en
avant c'est savoir faire la preuve avec
ce fabricant de basket qui a
confectionné une paire spéciale aux
couleurs du Tour précision recueillie
par Alain Druon pour cet aliment donc
voilà les éléments qui ont été imprimés
donc bien entendu avec le logo du Tour
de France pour l'occasion le choix était
de réaliser en fait une impression et
bien entendu on a mis à l'honneur
Limoges extérieur pour que ça ressorte
bien il y a un projet qui était accepté
par un asso donc la société qui organise
le tour et surtout en lien avec
le secteur communication de la Ville qui
m'a bien évité là-dedans donc le but
c'est vraiment de c'est un objet de
communication qui va me permettre de
donner un peu de visibilité à la marque
de montrer qu'à Limoges on fait de la
porcelaine mais aussi on fait aussi des
baskets et du coup moi c'est un peu
lâché dans la personnalisation en
faisant un produit qui est on va dire
fun en fait au coloris
allez une belle histoire à présent dans
ce journal celle de Gabriel un enfant de
13 ans et de noisettes une vache les
deux complices sont noués une étonnante
relation depuis que le premier a sauvé
la seconde de l'abattoir une histoire
d'amitié dont vous voyez quelques images
et qui sera bientôt mise à l'honneur
dans une émission de France Télévisions
propos recueilli par Nil ferrani pour la
Dépêche du Midi notre partenaire
j'ai toujours rêvé d'avoir une vache et
de les lever au biberon vu que j'en
avais trois avant le matin je fais la
nourrir et après je vais directement
travailler avec elle une heure par jour
le but c'est de pouvoir faire des
camarades avec elle pouvoir m'amuser
avec elle pourra la monter pour lui
faire faire des petits tours pour les
cabarets voilà une belle complicité
entre l'homme et l'animal qui nous
conduit en Isère à la rencontre cette
fois-ci d'un chien truffier et de son
maître Pascal filuseau un tandem qui a
du flair pour rechercher et trouver le
roi des champignons comme a pu le
constater Mirko petchi pour Télé
Grenoble
à l'ombre de vieux chaînes au pied de la
Chartreuse un chien et son maître
chassent le roi des champignons la
truffe noire toujours muni de son
cavadou Pascal filuso est un redoutable
caveur passionné ça fait plus de 20 ans
que je suis dans la truffe et là ça fait
20 ans que je suis en Isère je suis
bouché actuellement voilà donc en dehors
de ça je fais je fais ce un peu un
plaisir d'aller sur les marchés à
rencontrer des gens il existe 60 espèces
de truffes ce qui permet au rabatier de
débusquer toute l'année certaines
espèces battent des records de prix
comme la truffe blanche d'Alba qui est
vendu à 7000 euros le kilo dans la
Truffière de Pascal on récolte cinq
espèces dont la mélano d'hiver les
stivions d'été ou encore lucinatum
d'automne que l'intrus noir allait
beaucoup plus reconnue parce qu'elle a
plus de parfums et que la truffe d'été
plus ou moins elle est c'est une truffe
qui a pas d'odeur mais elle a elle a un
avantage c'est que la truffe d'été fait
au moins cinq fois réfléchir que que la
truc d'hiver
est un chien de romagnole une race dotée
d'une volonté de fer et d'une grande
faculté d'adaptation autrefois c'était
le port qui était exploité mais il a été
progressivement remplacé par le chien
plus obéissant et léger encore faut-il
l'entraîner la récolter fructueuse en
une dizaine de minutes tonnerre a trouvé
11 truffes blanches de quoi préparer
brouillard ou autre beurre de truffe en
Isère on compte 6 espèces différentes
alors à vos pioches pour dénicher ses
diamants noirs
voilà et c'était que diriez-vous aussi
d'en savoir un peu plus sur l'époque
néolithique c'est l'expérience proposée
en Corse par une association grâce à la
reconstitution d'un village sur un site
préhistorique les visiteurs peuvent
notamment y découvrir les activités et
les méthodes employées pour la
confection d'outils de l'époque images
et précision au micro d'Angèle richardy
pour télépaser
le principe ici chacun a sa spécialité
c'est de refaire les mêmes objets qui
ont été retrouvés dans une fouille avec
les mêmes techniques qu'on avait à
l'époque là je suis en train de polir
une hache du coup folie
brillant
parfois on est là pour ça pour montrer
tout ce qui était tout ce qui était fait
à cette époque donc on est vraiment
amené à
animer ce site de cette façon et
répondre aux questions quand on a la
réponse allez on referme ce journal avec
un bon de plusieurs millénaires dans le
temps pour nous glisser dans les
coulisses d'une vente aux enchères
exceptionnelles celle du manque
classique pour l'occasion des modèles
mythiques sont mis à la vente une
occasion s'emparer d'approcher les plus
belles carrosseries du monde et de se
plonger dans l'histoire du circuit du
Mans et du Sport Automobile un sujet
d'Enzo ma mère pour elle MTV ça
cellules des plus importantes vente aux
enchères de voitures de collection en
France Lotus Mercedes Bugatti Aston
Martin depuis 2010 la maison arcurial
fait craquer les acheteurs du manque
classique dans ce temple de la
carrosserie rutilante on s'arrache les
plus beaux bolides et les plus belles
histoires aussi lorsque l'on présente
une voiture qui s'est illustrée au 24
Heures du Mans peu importe l'époque ici
la vendre en plein cœur du circuit à
côté de la prégrille ça prend une vraie
résonance et un vrai sens historique
revenons quelques jours avant lors de
l'exposition un moment bien plus calme
loin de la foule pour y découvrir l'une
des pièces maîtresses de la vente je
vous accompagne vers une si ce n'est la
star de cette vente du manque classique
cette année c'est une Porsche 962 C qui
est engagé par une équipe japonaise au
24 heures du Mans en 19
et cette voiture jusqu'à la dernière
heure de course elle occupe la quatrième
place devant elle une autre Porsche 962
occupe la troisième place et d'un coup
la voiture a un problème mécanique elle
doit abandonner et finalement c'est
celle-ci qui va se retrouver sur la
troisième marche du podium elle est
estimée entre un million cinq et un
million 800000 euros un prix à en faire
tourner la tête comme presque tout ici
mais ce qu'on vient d'acheter avant tout
ce sont des morceaux d'histoire comme
cette relique de l'accident de 1955
c'est le couvre habitacle on le voit ici
sur la photo qui venait fermer en fait
la partie inoccupée pour parfaire
l'aérodynamisme de la voiture et cette
pièce durant l'accident a été projetée
elle a été récupérée par un commissaire
de piste aux abords du circuit et elle
s'est ensuite transmise pour arriver
aujourd'hui à la vente aux enchères
[Applaudissements]
a après une belle bataille
quand un autre star du jour
[Musique]
une vente en dessous de l'estimation qui
reste quand même l'une des plus élevées
de la journée l'acheteur lui et anonyme
aux enchères c'est bien connu les belles
ventes gardent toujours leur lot de
secret
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi le grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]